i lie all the time i say [ __ ] up
things i've done
you know not only how many episodes of
this have we done 300 do we have
applause i've done
i have another podcast to do i've done a
lot of those as well i've done everyone
else's i've done radio i mean i've
talked so many times and obviously you
can dig up [ __ ] but it's getting to the
point where my friend i can't name his
name but
he's a comic and 20 years ago he did
about 15 years ago did a podcast and the
host said
say the n word he's like i'm not gonna
ever i never say that word just as a
joke my fans will you know i mean so we
just said it like really quickly but now
he he's a writer
he can't get a he can't get a job that's
a black show right he just can't you
know i mean and it's like
you know i've had a lot of problems you
know in terms of cancer culture and this
and that and i've had to now
you know
curb
what i say yeah and edit
and it [ __ ] sucks and it's brought me
more toward the right
just in terms of
here's the thing
we've lost
the word redemption right in our
in our vocabulary right there is no way
we're not we can we'll chastise somebody
ruin somebody's career but there's no
forgiveness there's no there's no ch
even if i change
and i do the work to better myself or
whatnot there's no room for that anymore
and it's just i don't want to live in a
society like that yeah it's very
unforgiving it's so unforgiving i mean i
think you can be on a podcast i could be
on a podcast like this
and say something like
you know
whatever uh i will never say this
disgusting word and say that disgusting
word in the context of text saying i
will never say it yeah and someone will
say he said it on a podcast and now he's
canceled and they'll just clip they'll
just clip that word which they'd be
wrong but you know what he
he's he's sort of like
why are you smiling i'm smiling at you
dude because i'm trying to navigate this
thing yeah i i see you thinking i don't
i know just formulas all over you
because this is because rogan is like
family to me right sure i've done his
show i liked you yeah i liked joe a lot
right so it's like you know
some of the things he said
i don't fully agree with some of the
covert stuff i don't agree with but at
the end of the day it's like even if
i saw this i've said this before i saw
this girl
in indiana and she was in a grocery
store
and she's anti-vaxx anti-mask and she
kind of spit on
a woman that was telling her to wear a
mask
right that's assault yeah and i think
that she should have gone to jail right
but she got fired from her job yeah
and i that's just that's just a step
too far so one thing has nothing to do
with the other in my opinion you know um
it depends what they're doing for a
living like if there if there is an
outwardly racist woman calling another
person
and she works as a teacher in a
predominantly asian school like that one
right or working on a chinese problem
yes
it feels weird yeah yeah yeah yeah so
it's like probably gonna get cancelled
but you have to understand
don't this is what we've been dealing
with for the last couple of years it's
so sensitive but he showed but drogan
showed us a way
to kind of navigate through it yeah yeah
i thought that his responses were really
good yeah on both things and he's got a
massive platform which helps him from a
daily excuse me from a daily basis he
can keep revising those things trying to
improve on those things i caught heat
because
when he made that post which seemed to
be outside his house where he's like hey
guys
i realized spotify got in touch you know
joni mitchell left and neil young left
and that's unfortunate i'm a huge neil
young fan
i'm gonna try and maybe educate myself a
little bit more on some of these things
that i'm talking about maybe bring in an
expert maybe we'll have a little
disclaimer at the bottom of my podcast
yeah i'm gonna try and do better my bad
love you guys see you later so on his
instagram i wrote and i said hey joe
just want to say that's cool that you
held your hands up and said i think i
made some mistakes and i'm going to try
and do better i applaud that whatever
people like you're anti-vex you support
a racist person you did i said no no i
don't support some of the things that
joe said that he supported what i
supported is another human being saying
i [ __ ] up i'm gonna try and improve we
should all be able to support that yeah
the sensitivity in this culture is
outrageous and they're righteous but is
it like that in england
uh maybe less so than the states but
it's still around and everywhere is
influenced by the state it all starts
here yeah such a loud influential
culture
but i i can slightly navigate through it
because i can kind of be like well my
job is an actor of course i have a
podcast with billy
but like you know for the most part i
can just be like look i play characters
and my opinion is something that i want
to keep to myself i feel
worse for people like you guys and
especially people in comedy who are like
i'm on stage
trying some stuff out and and spitting
stuff and seeing what sticks yeah and
now people are like well you can't be
impulsive now because if you say
something impulsively upsetting we can
cancel you yeah
you know
that being said i have done stuff like
there's something because you know
during the pandemic i didn't go up
and a lot of this culture shift happened
in that time period in the last three
four years whatever right and when i
came back to do stand-up there was one
joke i can't tell what dirk joker was
but it's a longer bit
and i kept trying it and trying it and
they just wouldn't laugh
i would just eat it
and when i thought about it i went
i think it's my ego and like i'm gonna
make this work you know i mean but
fundamentally the joke
is mean well it's [ __ ] up it's [ __ ]
up and mean and i used to get laughs
with all these [ __ ] up things i would
say on stage and it's just like you know
what i need to grow as an artist and i
have to be more sensitive because if
there's no love in the joke it's just
kind of weird you know what i mean i
wish i could tell you
off camera yeah
off camera but um yeah it's pretty
insensitive to me it's still funny yeah
when i think of the joke i laugh and
when i'm doing the joke i'm laughing
because i love it
right just stop
i mean sometimes sometimes insensitive
things are funny because the punch line
is so shockingly incense ridiculous that
you have to laugh but i think
unfortunately we are never living in a
culture where people like well we have
to be more sensitive about what we what
we get out there and i've also benefited
from the culture changing i'm working
more now
i'm so glad we haven't didn't because
we're at the end we don't have to talk
about sex in the city oh i want it
we don't have to talk about it
did you can you separate the art from
the artist though can you still listen
to old bill cosby records can you listen
to michael jackson records
knowing what you assume listen i we
watched my so my brother i was just at
my parents my mom's house in arizona and
i just drove back yesterday right so i
was with my brother and my brother
didn't see the bill cosby documentary
so we watched it and he's like well he's
obviously a pedophile on the i mean a
rapist and not a painful